this video brought to you by the fine
folks at tea blocks tea blocks is an
affordable subscription-based service
that delivers custom t-shirts straight
to your doorstep with licensed art from
Marvel DC Disney Star Wars Naruto Game
of Thrones Breaking Bad and a whole lot
more you can support my channel today
and get 10% off your first order with a
special promo code Godzilla tbx go get
some cool shirts boys and girls this
time we're also running a special
Godzilla Mendoza giveaway for a free
first month for a key block subscription
follow the instructions in the
description for more information while
say that 10 times fast well Hulk is kind
of sort of mainstream again after being
featured as the buddy in the hit new
buddy comedy Thor Fraggle Rock
Thor rags-to-riches Thor tired of
wearing the wig all the time
Thor what meek do in the shadows planet
whole fun fact it's actually a nose and
not just a really high up mouth whatever
intros are hard you guys came to see a
game review we're gonna figure out which
was the best 3d Hulk game excluding that
ps1 game because I can't find a copy of
it so let's hop on back to the
forgettable year of 2003 where Ninja
Turtles roamed the streets
spider-man was on the complete wrong TV
channel and everyone acted surprised
when it got cancelled for some reason
and the depressive Green Giant got his
first movie by the director of Crouching
white Tiger Hidden Fin Fang Foom I
present to you the in Fraggle krong the
story is mostly just excuses to get to
random set pieces and fight hordes of
bad guys a coalition of villains steal
some of the Hulk's gamma power and
attempt to take over the world with it
while he smashes his way there to get it
back nothing too complicated it's a
means to an end
the graphics are done in this sort of
semi cel shaded style and I'm like 80%
sure it was just to hide that the
character models weren't very good
everyone looks vaguely like the cast of
that boring movie and they speak like
they just saw that boring movie
Betty my entire life I need to avoid the
military it's been a year since they
hunted me I won't be taken back i ruse
stomp the leader is building a gamma
army you must escape and we'll cover the
earth I've got to know the pairs of
symbols until I get a matching Cirrus
report to socialism if you wanted you
find it come on to us man they should
have just got egoraptor to voice them
again it just so happens I'm a kind of a
specialist on gamma bombs right off the
bat I like how this game varies it's
paced by throwing in stealth sequences
as Bruce Banner I'm sure when it came
out people must have hated it but I
think it's very fitting for the
character the focus on banners character
is duality between himself and the Hulk
and how they're different people sharing
a body it's interesting to have to solve
problems in a smart way and a brute
force way I enjoy the different tones
offered by each section
Hulk missions always feel like panic
chase sequences where you're rampaging
after some bad guy or trying to save
someone or you gotta escape from
somewhere in the banner missions it's
slow and methodical with focus on
planning out your moves instead of just
whacking the problem to death while
playing is the Hulk it's really about
just smashing your way through hordes of
enemies and breaking things to make it
easier to break other things it's very
linear but the combat is fun if a little
stiff the most important thing is
feeling strong and it does a good job of
that seems like a step in the right
direction though it doesn't offer much
to talk about the boss fights are pretty
solid too often requiring a little more
thought than just a straight-up slugfest
my favorite is the first one where you
can't hit the bad guy without making him
stronger and you have to use the
environment to beat him good bosses no
complaints somatically the stealth
sections are appropriate but my problems
are with them mechanically the thing
that holds back these levels is the
camera placement and movement usually
the camera is just stuck in one spot you
have no idea what's around the corner
sometimes you could just walk into a
spotlight and get your ass stomped by
feds like The Punisher that one time he
was black another level has you in a
disguise and the enemies only aggro when
you get too close to them so you could
just walk through a door
bump into some scientist that tanks the
whole mission
[Music]
I guess this bad camera placement helps
justify this weird mechanic where you
pull the trigger and go into a
stationary first-person view like the
whole purpose of this is to just get a
better look at things before you run in
headfirst into them and look like an
idiot though I'm not sure what point
there wasn't keeping this mechanic
during the Hulk sequences because he
seems pretty capable it's also hard to
choke out guards when they walk like 50
times faster than you can crotch walk so
sometimes you'll just run up behind them
pulsing they can strangle them that way
I often found myself rolling into them
on accident and knocking them on their
ass with my ass which led to my ass
being grass and of course my jaw it's
glass I mean I don't mean to be crass
but I'm giving this fight a hard pass
whoa well that's a lot of guards I'm
just gonna chill over here don't mind me
guys just taking a smoke break or
whatever people did in 2003 before they
had phones stare at hey what's up just
uh drop the contact lens scuse me pardon
me let me just walk on by you there
another thing you get to do while
playing is banner is putting up that
college education to good use in hacking
government computers to accomplish
various dumb tasks like mixing chemicals
and shutting down automated guard towers
of whatever it's a simple little
minigame switch out pairs of numbers and
letters until the one on the bottom
matches the one on the top
I'll give it points in that I've never
really seen a hacking minigame like this
before and it's more fun than just
clicking random words until you get one
right or connecting pipes together for
20 minutes the first few times you do it
it's simple enough but damn does it feel
like a hassle later like here I have to
mix this chemical that will make me turn
into the Hulk again hey wait a minute I
thought the whole point was to stop
turning into the Hulk so I could get my
life back what the hell am i doing I
should just escape this is frustrating
ah now look what you made me do they
give you such a strict time limit in so
many symbols to worry about that it's
extremely difficult to match up the
sequences it feels like it comes down to
luck because sometimes the random number
generation jumbles up the code so much
that the first number could be the exact
opposite end which means you have to
slowly move it back to the front and
make all the other symbols even more
mixed up by the time you get back to
them and by the time you get back to
those you've already burnt through a
huge portion of the time limit after a
while I started to get really good at
the hacking game but I feel like I'm
missing another mechanic here like I
screwed up and didn't listen closely
enough to the tutorial so there's
another button to randomize the entire
code or switch it to the opposite end or
something is that in there am I crazy
sometimes you get lucky with the RNG and
it's just close enough to the original
pattern that you can barely squeaked by
under the time limit and win hey do you
guys remember we're playing a game about
the Hulk big green fella smashes stuff
strongest there is no all right back to
hacking I can hack a real computer in
the time it takes to do this what the
hell there we go oh I did it I feel like
there's not a lot of Hulk stuff to talk
about in this one I mean I kind of like
all the bosses you have to fight and the
final encounter with leader is pretty
cool because it requires the input from
both banner and Hulk to win making the
two of them feel a little less at odds
overall this one has some annoying stuff
that holds it back from being more fun
than it could have been and it shows its
age a lot but I didn't have a terrible
time playing it and I might even try it
again sometime so I'll give this one a
recommend if you like the Hulk in your
very board don't you just love when a
game ends by baiting a sequel that never
happened it's kind of common actually in
superhero games this one ended up
leaving most people unimpressed when it
came out and I can't say it's gotten
better as time went on it hasn't gotten
worse or anything just not better
thankfully though radical games was
determined to improve upon this one
while the whole trend was still
relatively bankable and followed it up
with a sequel you might have heard of
tune in next time to find out if this
one holds up as well as we remember it
and asked the question is Hulk ultimate
destroyer
she's still awesome the answer is yes
what what the hell was that
move man they should put that in front
of the MCU movies
[Music]
[Music]